- Okay, good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to COP350, building
and validating cloud controls.
Make sure all of you have your headsets on
so you don't miss out on the
fun that I'm about to speak.
And thank you for joining us
today, late in the afternoon.
So my name is Pal Patel.
I am a senior solutions architect,
specializing in cloud governance on AWS.
And I'm joined today by Rodolfo Brenes,
who is a principal solutions architect
on the same team with me.
So every time I open my Amazon app,
I recently bought a home,
so I do a lot of purchasing,
or I'm doing a lot of purchasing lately.
I tell myself that I'm
only going to buy one item,
just one, a $20 item.
But 10 minutes later,
my cart looks like I am going
to open a new data center.
I add one cable, and somehow
I end up with a standing desk,
a label printer, another monitor arm,
and a chair named after
a Scandinavian forest.
And all this while Amazon is on the side,
going like, "Yeah, people who bought this,
they bought a whole new
lifestyle on Amazon."
I'm like, "Yeah, I feel great
about finding all these products,
but my credit card, not so much."
So if only I had like
this intelligent guardrail
for my shopping cart that would go like,
not like, "Stop, do not buy this."
But more like,
"Hey, maybe you don't need
this third monitor arm,"
or, "This is the duplicate
of the item I bought,
panic bought last week."
And then it's it more like...
And, sorry, so where was I?
Yeah, imagine I had like a
guardrail for my shopping cart
that would not just stop me,
but quietly nudge me
to make right decisions
and kind of safeguard my bank balance.
Now, thankfully, I do
have my husband for that.
Like, we share my Amazon account.
So next morning, most of the
items in my cart do disappear
and only the items that
he thinks we need remains.
I call it unauthorized access,
but he calls it cost optimization.
So now going from there,
just like my cart needs
intelligent guardrails,
so does your Amazon AWS environment.
And how do we do that?
That's what we are going to
explore through this session.
So I have a really
simple agenda for today.
I will briefly start exploring
with the pressure that people feel
to innovate while still
maintaining security and governance
in their environment.
Then Rodolfo here will deep dive
into the foundations of AWS
governance services on AWS
and then also talking
about some latest launches
for these services.
And finally, I will demonstrate
how generative AI can accelerate
the governance for you.
So in my day-to-day
conversations with customers,
when I talk about governance,
it's not so much about how to innovate,
but it's about how to
accelerate and automate safely.
Like, think about it, a single team today,
they can launch hundreds of thousands
of dollar worths cloud
resources within minutes.
But if you have to track their ownership,
if you have to maintain their governance,
their compliance, that can take time.
Like, people today are
building AI models within days,
but getting them shipped
and deployed in production,
it takes time, and for good reasons.
So businesses, they expect speed,
but governance expects
assurance, and it takes time.
And deployments and reviews, they are not,
or they often move at
fundamentally different speed.
So the opportunity here is clear,
like, governance shouldn't slow us down,
but we have to find, like,
ways to accelerate it,
validate it,
but without losing the
assurance that it provides.
So you don't scale mistakes
instead of your environment.
So, how do you do that?
How do you accelerate governance?
And that is where generative
AI can really help,
and which is what I'm going to
explore through this session.
So it can really help
shift your governance
from being a gatekeeper, or
just a gatekeeper to an enabler.
So imagine, instead of
manually reviewing compliance
for multiple AWS accounts,
you would just describe
that in a natural language
and it could give you
automated compliance checks,
or crafting a custom config rule
that can take days for you,
you would just describe in plain English,
and have an automated
deployable config control.
And for audit reasons,
gen AI can correlate findings
from Config, CloudTrail,
Security Hub events,
and then show you the gaps
and suggest the remediations
that before even it
becomes a compliance issue.
So moving on from these possibilities,
let's talk about
real-world implementation.
So I want to introduce you to Nita,
who is a lead CloudOps
engineer at AnyCompany.
She's the builder behind the controls.
And her team is responsible
for managing 300 plus AWS accounts
compliant and operational.
And like many of you, she's
always looking for making
or deploying controls in a
faster, safer, and smarter way.
And that's where she
turned to explore gen AI,
not as a shortcut to governance,
but more as a way to remove the friction
from building controls.
Now, as Nita explored opportunities
to improve her team's governance,
these were the challenges
that stood out to her
for her environment,
maintaining consistent controls at scale.
So as her environments and
AWS accounts keeps growing,
it becomes increasingly important
for her to have consistent controls.
Then their governance today
is very much reactive.
So, like they have ways to
detect non-compliant issues,
but they have limited
capability to prevent the issues
or prevent the non-compliant
actions from happening.
And while they are using
Control Tower Account Factory
to seamlessly provision their accounts,
applying account customizations,
it takes significant time
and pressure for a team.
So this is where she brings in Bob.
And I'll hand over.
- Thank you, Pal.
All right, so let's talk
a little bit about Bob
and his role.
So Bob, in this AnyCompany example,
he's one of our AI leads,
and he's gonna work with
Nita's team, operations team,
to actually build a
governance strategy, right?
One of the key things that we
are focusing in this example
is that we're gonna
start with this strategy,
but it needs to be agile enough
to actually keep the pace
of the innovation that we
want to achieve, right?
But in order to get started,
we need to actually start
looking at the foundations.
And Bob starts exploring all
the different AWS services
that can actually help us with this.
And, well, let's start with a very basic,
one of the longstanding services in AWS,
that is CloudTrail, right?
CloudTrail allows you to capture events
from, let's say, console logins, right,
control plane events, to data events,
to network activity events, right?
What is the activity
that is going through your
VPC endpoints, for example.
It allows you to capture all that activity
and actually aggregate that, store that,
could be in S3, could
be in CloudWatch Logs,
and allows you to take
actions on it, right?
What happens is if somebody
created an new EC2, right?
Who created it?
And then you can run investigations of it.
And you can review that from places
that you can store that on S3,
you can actually deploy
your dashboards on it,
or you can actually use managed services
like CloudTrail Lake in order to do that.
Well, he started looking at CloudTrail,
say, "Okay, let's take a look
on what has been launched
in the past few months."
So we're gonna focus,
we're gonna start actually
looking at the two
that are related here for data events.
As I mentioned,
data events is one of the
types of CloudTrail activity
that can be tracked
using AWS as a service.
So these normally are high-volume events.
So, for example, it is tracking
how many objects has
been stored on S3, right?
How many invocations to your lambdas?
And that could be, like,
a lot of logs, right?
So data events insights
allows you to, the tech anomalies here,
and this is something
that it has been available
for management events.
Now, it available for data events as well.
So allows you to actually realize
that something abnormal is happening
so you can actually review those.
And event aggregation is
for those high-volumes,
allows you to identify patterns.
What it's doing is actually
taking that information,
aggregate that on five-minute windows,
so you can actually
perform an investigation
to see if there's something
that has been happening
in the past few days, right?
So it allows you to ease
those investigations
on those data events that
you're getting from there.
And the last one that he realized
that it was launched is
CloudTrail Lake Event Enrichment.
So, as I mentioned, CloudTrail
Lake is a managed data store
that allows customers to aggregate data
from their whole organization
in one single place.
And then on that, you can
actually provide business context
into that event, right?
And this is done through, for example,
tax and the resources
that are been involved,
or the principles that were
actually taking that action.
So this is a very powerful mechanism
that Bob starts realizing that
they can definitely leverage.
And also, he realize that the event size
has been actually increased,
from 256 kilobytes to one megabyte.
So now all that enrichment can be done
and can provide you context
while you're doing investigations.
So, this is one of the
things that he starts doing,
and then say, "Well, definitely
context is very important,
what else is there?"
So he stumbles into Config.
Config is a service
that actually aggregates
and sits on top of CloudTrail data
and provides that configuration
history of that resource.
So gives you metadata on
that particular resource,
gives you the historical changes
based on, let's say,
compliance evaluation.
So it allows you to actually
assess that configuration
within your resources,
so you can run evaluations,
as Pal was explaining,
regarding to, let's say, if it is matching
on a specific steps, right?
If it's a desired configuration
that I want to have in there.
So this is basically when you
start setting up your controls
and making sure
that Pal is not buying more
stuff that she needs, right?
And it allows you to
remediate that on top of it.
So, let's say, it could be
natively done from Config,
or you can actually use
services like EventBridge
to remediate a non-compliance service.
And now, of course, at the end,
it provides you the capability
for you to audit your
environments in a certain way.
Let's say, following
a specific regulation,
or even internal policies that you have
and says, "Well, this is very good.
I have a couple of services
that can help me now."
Let's see what config
actually has launched
in the last few months.
The first one is the
service-linked recorder.
This is that we started the
year working with an integration
with what is called a
service-linked recorder
that allows other AWS services
to take actions on your
behalf using Config.
A great example of this is
the launch with CloudWatch.
CloudWatch now allows you
to actually take audit
on your telemetry data.
Let's say, if you wanna make sure
that all your EC2 instance
are using detail monitoring,
Config uses Config, I'm sorry,
CloudWatch uses Config data
to give you, let's say,
an evaluation of those resources,
as well as things like VPC flow logs,
or even having traces enabled
in your lambdas environments.
Security Hub, we just launched
the new experience yesterday.
It went GA.
And this also is using this.
So now you can just go to Security Hub,
enable what you need,
and it will be taken care
of Config on your behalf
using this integration.
And in terms of coverage,
we have been increasing the
automation around Config.
So now we, just last week,
we launched over, I think,
the couple of weeks before,
we just launched over 50 services
to the services that are covered,
as well as over 50 new managed rules.
And this is something
that keeps improving.
But then, as you start seeing,
there's a lot of changes
in these services.
So, start looking, "Okay,
is there something else
that can help me actually
build all this," right,
"in a managed way?"
And that's when we start
looking at Control Tower.
Control Tower allows me
to deploy a landing zone
where I'm gonna store all my resources,
and I can do that following best practices
for multi account, for example.
It allows me to establish that foundation
to eventually move forward
to how much I can automate
an account provision.
And this is also something
that is already embedded in the service.
And then I can start
working with controls.
There is a controls catalog
within Control Tower
that allows me not just to
deploy detective mechanisms,
but also going to, let's say,
preventive and proactive.
And with preventative,
I can actually go to AWS org policies,
I can deploy things like
service control policies,
resource control policies from the catalog
using the service.
And let's take on what is
new in Control Tower as well.
So Bob's realized
that there is a
comprehensive control catalog
that was launched actually last week.
And now he, even though
maybe he don't need to start
with the landing zone right now,
he just wants to go and start
deploying those controls
without actually taking that path
into a multi-cloud just now.
So the control catalog now can be accessed
individually of the landing zone setting.
So now you can explore
those controls easily
and deploy those if needed.
And then, again, auto enrollment accounts
is something that it was launched
a few weeks back as well.
This allows you to actually
migrate accounts easier
into Control Tower.
All those prerequisites
that sometimes it was a
blocker for some customers,
now they can actually do that easily
because the service actually
preparing the account
to be migrated into Control Tower.
And then finally, the
service-linked config rules.
As I mentioned, those integrations,
what this is doing is basically
I'm now, from Control Tower,
I can deploy config rules,
and I'm totally confident
that maybe somebody
with access to my member accounts,
even with permissions in Config,
they cannot touch those rules.
So those becoming mutable rules.
And he says, "Okay, all good."
But then now I have three services,
and a lot of our services
maybe even underlying Control Tower,
and we just saw only three,
and we saw that there
were a lot of updates
on each one of them.
So how can I actually keep
the pace on these things?
So this is when generative
AI actually comes in handy.
And the main service that we're
gonna explore today is Kiro.
Kiro is a conversional assistant
powered by AI, of course,
that is helping developers
and IT professionals
to write code, run test
on what you're doing,
access to AWS APIs.
And this is when we start looking
at how we can embed Kiro into AWS, right,
into my AWS environment.
So I can install Kiro in my AWS CLI,
and I can actually take context
and actually deploy commands
and do those centrally from my terminal,
or even from CloudTrail in AWS.
I can deploy code and I
can connect to MCP servers,
and deploy agents in those MCP servers.
So it comes with also with the
capabilities of agentic AI.
You can have rationalization
in those natural language conversations
with the agent to come up
with a strategy, right?
And that's sort of the things
that definitely it's something
that it can take a look on.
And then he realized
that AWS also provides
managed MCP servers, right?
So this is the capability
for you to don't be worried
about the standardization,
how many IPIs are actually in the backend.
CloudTrail is a good example of this.
They also launch and CloudTrail MCP server
that allows you to even run queries
without actually knowing
how to run those queries.
So you can actually
just have a conversation
to run investigations
using these kind of things.
And then you can leverage
knowledge MCP servers from AWS
to actually start doing
all the cool stuff,
the real cool stuff.
And that's when I'm
gonna move back to Pal,
that she's gonna explain
actually how to do all this
and how can she automate her husband.
- So it is the demo time.
Now, before we move on to the demo,
I quickly wanna share the
current test environment
that Nita's team built
for exploring these
generative AI capabilities
for accelerating governance.
So on the top you have
the management account.
It is a standard Control
Tower landing zone
that I have built on behalf of Nita,
and it has five organization units
that you can see on the right-hand side,
and it has about 18 accounts,
And for the most of the
demos that I have prepared,
we will be deploying it over the Labs OU.
And then on the bottom part,
you can see some of the shared
services, standard accounts,
log archive, and audit
accounts that come up
when you build landing zone
with the Control Tower.
So, with that, we are going
to really start simple
and with foundational rules,
that is how to create an
organization config rule.
And for all the...
I have prepared three demos in total.
And for all three,
I'm going to use Kiro CLI that
Bob introduced to my team.
So give me a sec here
to quickly change to my demo environment.
So I am starting here
with the Kiro CLI chat.
This is a default chat without passing in,
that comes up when you do not pass
any of the additional
arguments to Kiro CLI.
And I have loaded a
single MCP server here,
and that server is called
AWS MCP core server.
This is a really good server
to get started on using AWS MCP servers
because it utilizes dynamic proxy
to import other group of
servers based on roles.
Let's take a look what I mean.
So this is the MCP config
file that I've configured.
And you can see that I have
provided two roles here,
solutions architect and foundation.
Both of these roles are
like logical groupings
of MCP servers that are
commonly used together
for a specific use case.
So solutions architect role here,
it provides me access to MCP
servers such as knowledge,
AWS APIs, pricing, cost
explorer, et cetera.
While foundation, it gives
me access to knowledge,
as well as AWS API, MCP server.
Next, let's explore some of the tools
that come up with some
of these MCP servers.
An interesting one here
that core MCP server provides
this prompt understanding.
This tool really helps you
when you are designing AWS solutions
and using natural language to do it
because it really helps
translating your intent
in terms of what it means
and which services to utilize
and features and such.
Moving on, I have also
utilized knowledge base here.
So I have loaded the knowledge
about custom configures from AWS GitHub
into my knowledge base.
So knowledge command here,
it's like an experimental
feature on Kiro CLI right now
that helps you,
once you enable it, that
helps you store, search,
and manage additional
context across chat session.
And I have used best indexing type here
to index the knowledge base,
so that agent can do an
intelligent or a semantic search
against my knowledge base
whenever it requires to use that.
With that, I will move on
to create a basic organization config rule
that helps me detect EC2 instances
launched with public IP
address in my account.
And I'm asking the agent
to create the first fine,
if a managed config rule exists
for the similar use case.
If not, then go to the custom building,
the custom configure for that.
And also utilize knowledge
base in case it requires.
And finally use infrastructure
as code best practices.
So every action that it takes,
it can be traced back and audited.
So now, let's look
as the agent searches through
the knowledge base MCP server
to search through AWS documentation.
Then, for each of the tools here,
it is actually asking me for a permission
because I have not
trusted any of the tools.
But with t, I'm trusting all the tools
that are coming up
for the rest of the
duration of this session.
So let's watch it.
The agent also go,
went through the knowledge base
just to load the additional context
for custom rules in case it needs it.
It makes API calls to
my current environment
to find that there are no similar rules
already running in my account
to avoid any duplication.
And good news,
agent has found the
managed config rule for us,
and it is called
ec2-instance-no-public-ip.
Now,
next, you will see
that it'll create the required
CloudFormation templates
and files.
It'll create so in your
current working directory,
if you have not provided
any additional settings
in the config file.
And so it is utilizing my
current working directory.
It created...
Looking at the summary,
it created a CloudFormation template
for deploying the config rule.
It created a shell script
that will actually create
the CloudFormation stack,
and then a read me file.
So I reviewed the shell script,
and now I am going to
run that shell script
from within the session.
And you can do so
by proceeding your command
with an exclamation mark.
Looks like the deployment failed,
and this is where the fund begins
because now I can just ask Kiro CLI
to troubleshoot the issue for me
instead of me having to
go through multiple events
in the CloudTrail and correlate them.
So it quickly went through the
CloudFormation stack events,
it found the issue, and
it deleted the stack.
The issue is regarding the resource type
for the organization config rule
as it does not support rule ARN.
Instead, it returns rule name.
So you can see it making changes.
Whichever lines are in red,
it remove that from the template,
versus green is the addition.
So now it is waiting
for the stack to delete
before redeploying it.
It redeployed again.
And this time, you can notice
that it didn't wait for me
to explicitly tell him to troubleshoot,
or tell it to troubleshoot,
and instead, went ahead.
And again, the stack seems to have failed.
This time, the issue is
related to frequency parameter.
The ec2-no-public-ip config
rule is triggered by change.
So frequency is not a valid
parameter for this rule.
It quickly identifies the issue.
And it follows the same sequence,
deletes the stack, waits for the deletion,
and deploys the stack again,
Yay!
Third time was the charm,
and we have a successful stack deployment.
And hence, a successful deployment
of organization config rule.
It'll also provide the summary
of all the steps that it went through,
so all the issues that it found
And the resolution that it applied.
For the next part, I'm going to query.
So I have a config aggregator,
which is like you can
aggregate all the config events
from all your AWS accounts
in the organization
into a single account.
So I already have that deployed
by Control Tower in my audit
account that we previously saw.
And I'm using that to query
for the non-compliant instances
that were found
in respect to the rule
that we just deployed.
And we found three instances
across two AWS accounts that we can see.
So this kind of shows us how
easy it was for Nita's team
to do the research, do the deployment,
and even run the query for non-compliance,
all from within a single session,
without having to leave terminal.
With that, let me move on to my next demo.
So, with this, we are going to use agent
to implement shift left
strategy for controls.
So let's talk about shift left.
So, traditionally, compliance
and security controls
have had been added late in
the deployment lifecycle,
and sometimes the fixes,
it becomes costly,
it causes delay and also gaps in security.
So shift left,
it literally means
shifting left your controls
in the development lifecycle,
so you can detect the issues
earlier on and fix them
and not having to fix them later.
And what that means in
terms of AWS infrastructure
or what that means for Nita's team
is she's going to implement
two types of controls,
preventive controls,
which are powered by
service control policies
and apply it on organization,
and second is proactive controls,
which are powered by
CloudFormation Guard Hook
that can actually detect non-compliance
in your infrastructure templates
and block it
even before having to go
through the deployment.
So in this demo,
I will show you how Kiro helps implement
both the preventive,
as well as proactive controls,
and making it easier to
catch and stop issues
before they reach production.
So let me switch to my
demo environment again.
This time, instead of
using a default agent,
I created a new agent called
shift-left-specialist.
In the agent config file,
I defined such that the agent
is a special security architect,
and its expertise is to kind
of define or create shift left,
equivalent shift left controls
of a given config rule
or a given detective rule
in terms of both the preventive controls
as well as the proactive controls.
And for this agent, I
loaded to MCP servers.
I'm starting simple.
Oops.
Yeah, it's knowledge as well as API.
Now we do have AWS CLI tool
inside the Kiro CLI that
comes in by default.
So Kiro CLI can interact and call,
make AWS CLI calls to your infrastructure.
But I like to add API MCP
because I have noticed in all
the tests that it makes for,
or it quickly generates accurate API
or accurate CLI command
without doing many retries with the syntax
and the parameters that are supported.
So, moving on, let's
take a look at context.
So this time, I've
added an additional file
called shift-lift-bp-guide.
This is a context file
that provides some extra
information to the agent
about what is shift left,
how to author the preventive
as well as proactive controls on AWS.
And this is different
from the knowledge base.
It is simply increasing the context.
It's not something that
agent would search.
It's not indexed.
And this time,
you would see that there are
much less number of tools
than before because I have
just two MCP server loaded.
And on the permission,
you would also see that I've
pret trusted some of the tools
that I knew were going to get
used throughout this session,
like reading the files, calling AWS APIs.
And from knowledge MCP,
we have read and search
through the AWS documentation.
Now, the first part of shifting
or implementing shift left
is to identify what
non-compliant resources you have
through detective controls.
And that is what I'm asking it to do here
is to query the top two
non-compliant config rules
with most number of
non-compliant resources.
So let's watch as the agent again
knows to query the config
aggregator in my account,
it describes the rules
within the config aggregator,
think some more.
And based on the data it
collected, it gave me two rules.
So we have one is KMS tagged key.
This control really detects
which KMS keys are not tagged.
And the second control is
which lambda functions,
or production lambda
functions for not deployed
with X-Ray tracing enabled.
So now that we have that information,
I'm using editor command here
to provide somewhat of a longer prompt
that I already had prebuilt on the side.
And so by default, it opens a vi editor,
but you can set the editor
of your choice if you want.
And here, I am asking it to
develop the shift left controls.
And I'm specifically asking it
to deploy this through customization
for Control Tower
Pipeline, or CfCT solution.
If you're familiar with that solution,
it's, like, lets you
customize your AWS accounts
after they get provisioned
through Control Tower.
And I'm saying that for
the KMS config rule,
it should create a service control policy,
and only do it for the KMS keys
with cost and environment tags
and apply it on overall organization
that is just for simplicity.
For the lambda config rule,
I want to create a
CloudFormation Guard Hook
that will prevent the
non-compliant lambdas
to get created in the first place.
And I only want to deploy this control
on a specific organization
unit of my overall org.
So now, it has access
to my CfCT manifest file
through the current working directory.
And as the agent creates
and updates the files,
I'm going to shift through some of these
and get us through the part
where we can see the git summary
for what changes were implemented.
So I'll pause here.
And here, you would see
what were the changes
that were made by the agent.
And some files were changed,
while some were deleted and added.
This is because we were not successful
to deploy the controls in the first run.
So I had some troubleshooting
that I had to skip for in
the interest of time here.
But I'll just give you brief
summary of what happened.
So while it was very smooth
in creating the right SCP
for the KMS control,
like detecting which
KMS keys are not tagged,
it had some challenges
to create the CloudFormation Guard Hook.
And one of the challenge was
so CloudFormation Guard Hook,
it evaluates your,
it can evaluate your entire stack
and then decide whether
it should let the stack
to go ahead with the deployment or not.
And since I am creating
the hook with the stack,
I don't want that hook
to run against the stack that created it.
It's like a chicken and egg problem.
Now we do have a parameter in
the CloudFormation resource
to skip the tag from running,
or from getting evaluated by the hook,
and the agent required some back and forth
for it to find the exact parameter.
It's like a niche skill or parameter
that not everyone might know.
But I did not just feed that
information to the agent.
Instead, I asked it to go
through the public documentation
and through knowledge MCP server,
it has access to AWS docs, blogs,
as well as what's new
information, what's new posts.
So it was able to find that information
through a blog post that we have.
And now, here is the summary
of the commit that it'll make.
So here, I'm just again
running the command
to push the commit.
I didn't want agent to do it on this run.
And this, in the backend,
has started our pipeline,
or code pipeline for the customization
for Control Tower solution.
Again, I'm going to check on
the status of the code pipeline
that was triggered with this git push.
Let's see.
So now it knows the
exact API calls to make,
it lists the code pipeline
that I have available,
it lists the execution
of the given pipeline,
and also get the details
of the recent execution
or the most latest execution.
And it gives us the
status of the pipeline,
which is currently in progress.
So I waited for some time
for the pipeline deployment
to complete on the side
and check the status
of the pipeline again.
Again, it runs the same
command to list the pipeline.
And it shows us that the
pipeline has succeeded.
It has succeeded in all
the stages that it has.
Its total of six stages.
Now, from the same session,
I'm going to validate one of the controls,
which is CloudFormation
lambda hook, or Guard Hook,
that it created for
preventing lambda functions
or non-compliant lambda
functions from being created.
And so remember in the beginning
that I asked to deploy these
CloudFormation Guard Hook
only on the Labs OU, and the
Labs OU has two accounts.
And so it shows one of the
accounts to run that test.
But when I started this session,
I provided the credentials
for my management account
of my organization,
and so it quickly realizes
that it doesn't have access
to the member account.
So at this stage, I will ask the agent
to assume the Control Tower execution role
in one of these member
accounts and then tested.
Now I had to skip through the part
where it shows the entire test
because it prints the AWS
credentials on the screen,
which I did not want to
share for security reason.
So I'm just going to ask it
to print the results
of the validation test
that it performed instead.
And so that's the test environment,
one of the accounts in the
Labs OU you can see at the top.
And it created two tests,
one for the compliant lambda function
and one for the non-compliant.
In the compliant one,
the lambda function had
X-Ray tracing enabled,
as well as it was tagged with
the production environment key
that I'd passed in the original prompt,
and that was successful.
While for the non-compliant test,
we have the tag again, but it
was missing the X-Ray tracing.
So this deployment was blocked
by CloudFormation hook.
And that concludes my second demo.
And again, even this shows how
easy it was for Nita's team
to test the shift left
strategy for implementing
and how easily they can scale
across 300 plus accounts
that they have in their environment.
I'm going to shift
to our next and final demo of the session,
which is, again, I'm going
to use this same agent
to create an AWS account
and deploy SRA aligned patching solution.
So for those of you who may not know,
SRA is like a security
reference architecture.
It's like holistic
guideline that AWS provides
to implement, like, complete
set of security services
that we have following AWS best practices.
It has the whole GitHub
repository for this.
And so today, for this demo,
I'll use Kiro CLI to do two tasks.
One is to create an AWS account
and then deploy the SRA
align patching solution
on one of the existing accounts.
Actually, I'm doing it
on the Labs OU again,
just for simplicity.
So this is the architecture
of the SRA align patching
solution from the GitHub.
And you can see that it uses Patch Manager
from Systems Manager along
with maintenance window
to run these appropriate
baselines and patch the instances.
So let's see how our agent
is able to interpret this
solution that I will feed
and implement the design
through CfCT code pipeline.
Oops, no, I want to switch.
So let me switch to my
third and final demo.
Again, we created,
I created a new agent
called create-AWS-account,
which specializes in
provisioning an AWS account
and also apply account customization.
Here, I've loaded three MCP servers.
Now, let's look at the knowledge base.
So I have added the
entire GitHub repository
of security reference
architecture in my knowledge base,
and again indexed it with best type,
so that agent can do an
intelligent search against this.
Let's look at the context.
So I've also added an additional file
about what are the general
foundational best practices
for account customization,
et cetera, in my context.
And you can also see
the percentage of context window it used.
It's not much.
So...
I'm going to use editor command,
and I will provide all
the required parameters
for creating an AWS account.
It's the usual one, email address, the OU,
organization account name, et cetera.
And let's watch as the agent.
So agent exactly knew
which method to create the account with,
which was to use service catalog product
that Control Tower already provides you
once you create your landing
zone with Control Tower.
So it searches my available products,
it searches the product
that Control Tower created.
It also finds the provisioning parameters
that are required for
deploying this product
through service catalog,
and then verifies if I have provided
all the parameters in my prompt.
So this line is important.
This is a heavy change that
will create an AWS account.
How did the agent determine
this is because I've defined
what a heavy change is in my context file
that I initially fed to my agent.
And so before making any
of the heavy changes,
I want the agent to ask
for my confirmation,
and that is what it exactly did.
And once I confirm,
it goes ahead to create
the service catalog product
that will provision
the AWS account for us.
I'm just going to check on the status
of the latest account that was created.
And here's the account
we have, really simple.
So for the next part,
now we are going to
apply the customization,
the SRA align patching solution
that we previously saw.
And for that, I'm asking agent to take,
again, it has the context
about my current working
directory, my CfCT solution,
my pipeline, and the SRA solu,
sorry, security reference
architecture documentation,
or the GitHub repo that I fed
in through the knowledge base.
So you can see how it searches
through different things.
It goes through my
current working directory
to find the manifest file.
It understands that.
Then it searches the knowledge base
for the reference architecture
and finds relevant,
tries to find the relevant components
of the patching solution
to design the patching
solution that I asked for.
And looking at the deployment
plan that it provides,
it provides the current
state architecture,
the existing ones, existing
resources that I already have,
and the future state architecture.
And for the future state,
it provides me with two
CloudFormation templates
that is going to deploy
my patching solution.
One is the prerequisite template
that has the prerequisite
for creating the baselines
or the maintenance window, et cetera,
and second is the main solution
that will actually deploy
the maintenance window.
So here, we have three maintenance window.
One is going to update the SSM agent
that is required for the patching.
Second is run the maintenance for,
sorry, run the patching for Windows.
And third is random patching
for Linux instances.
We can also take a look
at some of the key
configuration parameters,
like, what is the schedule
of my maintenance window?
Do I want to run the
patching in the install mode
or the scan mode?
And I have not provided
any of this to the agent.
All I have done is provided the prompt
that we saw in the beginning.
So it identified some
of the key parameters
that needs confirmation from me.
One is I did not mention
where to deploy the solution.
So it is confirming if it
should start with the Labs OU
because it has knowledge of my environment
It picked the Labs OU
based on the name, I guess.
It asks whether I want
to patch in the scan mode
or directly go to the install mode.
Are the schedules okay?
Do I have EC2 instances already tagged?
And I'm going to provide all answers
to all the questions here.
Sorry for the text, it is at the bottom,
but I couldn't scroll it at that point.
So now, now that it has confirmation,
it moves on to create the
CloudFormation templates
and all the other required files.
Let me skip us some of this
and get us through the git summary,
so that we can look at the changes.
So we saw that it created
two CloudFormation templates,
one for the prerequisites,
one is the main solution,
this is the manifest file which controls
where the CloudFormation
stack sets would be deployed,
which is Labs OU only.
And then it also provides
me with a markdown file
of what all the changes it did and how.
So I'm going to ask it
to commit the changes,
which will trigger our code
pipeline in the backend.
And this time, it already had
the command to do a git push.
So when I asked it to commit,
it also pushed the
commit to my repository.
So we are going to check
on the status of the code pipeline again.
It'll go through the
same sequence of events,
describing the pipeline,
the latest execution,
and getting the details for us.
So, currently, the pipeline is in progress
at the second stage,
which is the build stage.
Now, for this one, while I
was waiting for the demo,
I decided to experiment
with the tangent mode.
So tangent mode,
it kind of allows you to
have a side conversation
without spoiling the context
of your current environment
or whatever current session you have.
So here, I'm just asking it,
what are the some of
the top feature launches
at 2025 re:Invent,
specifically for organizations
and Control Tower services.
And you can see,
it searches through AWS documentation
using different set of keywords.
It also searches through the
what's new post and blog post
because we do announcements
through all these different channels.
And based on the search,
it provided a list of couple things.
Actually there were more in organizations,
like direct account transfer
and transfer billing.
You can see some of the announcement
that Rodolfo also spoke
about for Control Tower,
which is controls-only dedicated
experience, more rules,
more compliance frameworks, et cetera.
Now that we are done having fun,
let's get out of the tangent mode
and head back to check on
the status of our pipeline.
It makes the same CLI calls again.
And looks like we have a
successful pipeline deployment.
This was a really smooth experience.
Again, this shows how easy it
was for Nita's team to test.
Like sometimes, these
account customizations,
they get really complex.
And when it's, I mean, even for human,
it's kind of not every human would have
all the context necessary,
but it's easier to feed
like such large context
and knowledge base to
the agent and train it.
And we also saw that their team,
they kind of utilize these
specialized agents instead.
So having the agents do very
specific dedicated task.
And that's why they got great results.
So I also have one more demo here.
Let me switch.
I promise this is the last one.
It is just a validation of
what the agent deployed.
So now, I am in the management
account of my Control Tower
in the console,
and I'm going through the CloudFormation,
just to show you the stack
sets that it deployed.
So remember how we saw two stacks
that the agent provided us
for the patching solution.
One was the prerequisites,
other was the main solution.
So these are those two stack sets
that were created through the pipeline.
Let's go into one of these stack sets
and take a look that this was deployed
into two of our accounts,
which are under Labs OU.
And I'm going to log into one of the OUs,
one of the accounts that
I'm highlighting here.
So this is that account.
Again, I'm in the
CloudFormation stack window.
This is the stack it created.
And take a look at the timestamp.
If you noticed it in my last demo,
it should match with the
execution time of our pipeline,
just to confirm that these stacks
are actually from the that build.
So now, I am into the
Systems Manager console,
where I'm showing the three
maintenance window that we saw,
each for doing Linux
patching, Windows patching,
and just updating the SSM agents.
So let me get into the detail
of one of those windows,
which is for Linux.
I'll head into the task to
see actually what it created.
So it shows the default patch base,
sorry, default document
to run the patch baseline.
And then towards the bottom,
we will see the operations
type, which is Scan.
This is what I had prompted
in my earlier demo.
Oops, sorry,
I kind of...
Okay.
Next up, I just quickly
go into the targets.
So it selected the instance tags,
selected to specify, or select
instances based on the tags.
And these were the tags
that we had earlier
confirmed in our prompt.
And finally, this is the execution.
So if you remember, the schedule
of the maintenance window,
this is one of the last
executions that ran successfully.
Okay.
So that concludes the
end of all of my demos.
Now...
Oops.
Yeah.
So here are some additional
resources for you to review
before I summarize our
journey, or Nita's journey.
So first, you have cloud governance,
recent launches, and resources.
Second is Kiro CLI docs.
These are great docs
to get you started with
how to install Kiro CLI
and utilize all the niche commands
and the tools that it supports.
And last one is the AWS MCP Server GitHub,
which is where we publish MCP
servers for all the services,
or the CloudTrail one
that had also mentioned,
as well as all the other ones
that I utilized in my demo.
Now, to summarize Nita's journey,
like, if you think back why
they were successful was,
as I was talking earlier,
like, they utilized the agent's various,
for niche use cases,
they provided as much
context that was available.
They provided good examples
for each of the tasks
that wanted to implement.
And that is why it was
successful for them.
And more importantly, they started small,
like really simple from
a simple config rule
to deploying a complex
account customization.
And with each test,
it kind of built trust with their team
in how generative AI can help
accelerate the governance,
as well as controls for them.
So just start small,
think big, and scale fast,
and you can leverage Kiro CLI today
to accelerate the governance,
as well as controls.
And gen AI isn't just a tool.
It can really help you, like,
work smarter, not harder,
or at least it has helped
me a lot in my role.
Before you leave,
please drop by our CloudOps
kiosk in AWS Expo Hall,
and then you can have
more deeper conversations
around the stuff that you have seen today.
There, we have experts
that can also give you one-on-one demos
for all the cloud
governance-related services
and recent launches.
And also we have swags
and stickers for you,
if you like them.
Finally, thank you for your time.
And yeah, please don't forget to give,
take a session survey on your mobile app.
(audience clapping)
Thanks.